allez on continue avec vous toujours et
avec tous ces bons plans on était dans
la rentrée 2020 et je le disais c'est
une rentrée pas vraiment comme les
autres la preuve vous auriez dû être à
côté là au milieu du docteur brigitte
virey et de sébastien curie notre
artisan mais finalement vous vous
retrouvez banon à nous dans un autre
studio et ça fait plaisir quand même
bonjour tiffen failli faire merci d'être
au rendez vous bonjour pascal mon jour à
tous oui je suis un peu exilés mais j'ai
aussi apporté des livres comme
d'habitude pour cette rentrée alors
cette année j'ai plutôt des livres
parascolaires pour rassurer les parents
et les enfants et le premier va vous
plaire puisqu'il permet de développer sa
mémoire et sa concentration est ce que
vous connaissez le ni oui ni non
longtemps que j'étais fan ne c'est pas
grave je connais le ni oui ni non mais
si je réponds oui j'ai peur quand je dis
évidemment
et bien c'est un jeu très connu mais il
permet justement de développer sa
capacité de concentration et c'est un
jeu qui est parmi les 50 activités
bienveillante pour mieux se concentrer
cas compilés marine du vous dites dans
ce livre publié par larousse alors
figurez vous qu'il ya énormément
d'ateliers et de jeux
dans ce livre alors à chaque fois s'est
expliqué très simplement et il ya aussi
l'objectif pédagogique visé alors j'ai
beaucoup apprécié ce livre puisque c'est
assez simple et ici pas question est
bien de remplacer les professeurs non il
est juste question de s'amuser d'aider
ces enfants à prendre connaissance et
prendre conscience de leurs capacités
les développer ça s'adresse aux enfants
de 6 à 9 ans et ça leur permettra et
bien d'affronter la rentrée sereinement
et bien de prendre conscience qu'ils
sont capables d'apprendre les savoirs
les plus compliqués le plus facilement
du monde
l'idée celle des petits jeux par exemple
comme faire ses devoirs
debout ou méditer en marchant voilà je
le conseille à tous les parents super
tiphaine moi j'adore en plus c'était
sous le regard du docteur brigitte virey
qui est la pédiatre voulait les livres
vous en servez au quotidien j'imagine
vous demander aux parents aussi
d'acheter ce genre de livre des bons
livres
oui absolument puis nous nous avons en
plus les pédiatres nous avons une revue
et nous avons une pléiade qui fait
toutes les bibliothèques et en fonction
d'un thème et qui conseille des livres
et donc nous après nous pouvons
conseiller aux parents quand en face
d'une situation particulière nous
pouvons le conseiller des livres ça
c'est très bien joué mettre en relation
avec tiphaine sans ce site vous nous
avez d'ailleurs amené une autre méthode
a ainsi fait une méthode pour améliorer
l'apprentissage des leçons les cartes
mentales c'est ça c'est quoi allons nous
expliquer et bien le gars mental ça
ressemble à ça vous le voyez un schéma
qui explique une notion particulière
alors ici ce sont les fractions alors
vous le voyez il ya des petits dessins
voilà classique sur les fractions mais
assez amusant il ya aussi la manière de
les représenter et ce qu'est une
fraction alors ça c'est le recto et au
verso vous retrouver et bien le court
plus traditionnelle alors les cartes
mentales et bien ça permet de
représenter le court mais d'une manière
totalement schématique ça peut être très
utile pour les enfants qui ont une
mémoire photographique ou qui ont un peu
un problème avec le langage peut-être
parce qu'ils ont des difficultés
dysorthographie etc ou bien parce qu'ils
ne sont pas de langue maternelle
française alors eroles a eu la très
bonne idée de publier tous ces petits
pots frais ça concerne les mathématiques
le français l'anglais l'espagnol
ça commence à partir du cm1 mais il n'y
en a aussi pour le collège est de plus
en plus de professeurs utilisent ce
système avec leurs élèves pour qu'ils
apprennent à mémoriser leur cours voilà
ça couvre tout le programme de
mathématiques j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
intelligent et puis ça peut permettre
aux parents et bien de réviser avec
leurs enfants
voilà sans problème et puissants se
plonger dans des cours voilà de dizaines
de pages sur une carte vous avez et bien
toutes les fractions
c'est une vraie alternative aux cours
écrit traditionnel et nous on aime la ce
genre de bons plans pour les plus petits
à partir de la grande section vous avez
trouvé aussi un cahier d'apprentissage
avec un graphisme particulier ça vous a
beaucoup plu j'ai l'impression tiffen
oui alors vous savez des cahiers
d'apprentissage des méthodes
d'apprentissage de la lecture y en a
plein alors moi j'ai flashé sur celle-ci
cocorico je lis je sais lire cocorico je
sais lire de bordas l'idée ce n'est pas
d'apprendre forcément à l'ira
maison d'apprendre à écrire mais vous
savez il ya toujours l'envi d'exercer un
petit peu ses enfants et bien si je dois
conseiller un cahier d'écriture je
conseille celui ci sans hésiter puisque
je ne sais pas si vous le voyez bien
mais les modèles d'écriture sont à
droite et à gauche et ça je ne l'avais
jamais vu c'est à dire que c'est idéal
aussi pour les gauchers autre chose et
bien c'est avec les p'tites poules alors
les p'tites poules c'est un énorme
succès de librairie
c'est un livre de christian jolibois qui
est qui connaît d'ailleurs je vous le
signale et de christian english
alors si vous ne voyez pas ce que c'est
c'est ça les p'tites poules dix sept
tomes déjà publié un énorme succès de
librairie
les aventures deux p'tites poules car
mais carmen carmélites au cet idéal et
vraiment je me dis que si on apprend à
écrire et à lire avec ça et bien une
fois qu'on sait lire on lira ça et et
bien je vous le conseille une haute et
les petites poulenc le titre déjà c'est
absolument j'ai enfin typhaine pour
terminer vous voulez nous présenter un
album pour les enfants à partir de 5 ans
moi le titre m'a déjà beaucoup plus et 1
2 3 on le voit à l'école de marianne
dubuc essai publié par casterman
oui je me disais on peut finir avec une
nouveauté et avec un album puisqu'il n'y
a pas que le travail dans la vie
alors l'idée c'est que le héros est bien
voudrait aller à l'école mais il n'a pas
encore l'âge alors il met son enquête
pour savoir à quoi ressemble l'école et
il va visiter l'école des animaux les
lapins les souris et chacun une école un
peu différente il ya ceux qui apprennent
les savoirs pur et dur et puis les
grenouilles qui se consacre aux
activités vraiment artistique
alors il décide que son école idéale et
bien ce serait un petit peu de tout ça
et je me dis qu'en cette rentrée se
plonger dans des grands livres explorer
tous les détails et décidé d'inventer
son école idéale
et bien ce serait quand même une bonne
chose à faire super merci tu fais la
sélection lui m retrouvez aussi sur le
net
évidemment vous retrouvera très bientôt
dans ce joli studio j'en profite pour
remercier nos équipes techniques qui
font un boulot formidable parce que vous
l'aurez constaté on n'est pas dans dans
pantoufles si j'ose dire voilà il ya des
petites choses qui ont été modifiées qui
ont été changés et on s'adapte comme
vous comme nous tous voilà on va aussi
le masque et dès que les caméras sont
éteintes enfin voilà c'est la vie et la
vie elle est aussi comme ça aujourd'hui
à une prochaine fois tiffen oui à très
bientôt j'espère d'ailleurs il n'ya pas
de souci je compte sur vous